so tell me about your theory of
parenting you're very you've spoken
about you know your your relationship I
guess with your in-laws and obviously
you've mentioned your daughter although
she has a private personality and I want
to talk anything personal but what how
do you view being a father and and the
relationship you have with Pia and and
how do you how do you have a philosophy
or is it every day like your daily life
sounds like is a new beginning
[Music]
interesting question so are you a top
Lehrer fan yep
when you're exposed to Tom Lehrer as a
child all of the naughtiness of the
world has brought to your to your feet
and laid and I guess what I felt was
that my grandfather was part of this
where he showed me that the world wasn't
the way it was claimed to be and maybe
it's an intrinsically very Jewish thing
to constantly question the frame most
people did questions inside of a frame
and they answer the question to the best
of their ability and Jews tend to
question the frame they spot the
argument what is my philosophy that you
should let your kid drive well before
the age of 16 you should make sure that
your children know what alcohol tastes
like in trace amounts to rob it of its
mystery and its feel that drugs what
what about drugs it is a drug
what about hard schedule one drugs how
do you don't obviously don't want them
to dabble in it or psychedelics like Sam
Maris somebody else could decide that
that was a good I mean I have a friend
who's very well known I think we've been
trace amounts of schedule 1 substances
you make an argument that you schedule
what substances are safer mmm a certain
physiological sense personally do not
favor
getting inebriated on drugs it until
your brain it's pretty well-developed
mm-hmm so I very much worry um the the
purpose of getting a trace amount of
alcohol is to say oh that's what Scotch
tastes like it's no longer something I
need to sneak to know you know so the
the point isn't that you should get
drunk when you're a kid or you should
get hot when you're a kid the point is
you should try to prevent your children
from becoming alcoholics and in essence
another piece of my philosophy I guess
is don't push your children because you
can any person can turn their child into
a prodigy there's an emergency program
in the mind of a child that says if your
parents die grow up super fast and it
it's you know it's like a backup
parachute if your first parachute fails
so don't push your children but put
everything in front of them in case
they're ready for something super early
I had a situation with my son where my
son was without question the worst
musician of all time bar none could not
do anything he was used to he was
musically hopeless and then before he
turned 13 in six weeks he taught himself
four instruments while I was
procrastinating for his Torah portion
and that told me a lot that even though
I had been dutifully putting in front of
him and taking it away put in front of
taking away brain wasn't ready so don't
get into a thing where somebody else's
kid is you know one of my kids walked
and talked pretty young and the other
one didn't get involved in competition
about it your child's brain is
developing according to its own path and
neither your child and where you will
understand it well enough
do not become your child's best friend
ever
he yep there's plenty of mass from yours
you are something far more important
than the best friend the best friend
would be a demotion if you're a parent
so leave that spot open in your child's
life and teach your children to break
the rules and teach them how take
responsibility for the breaking of the
rules when you break the rules it's not
cheap mm-hmm so you should teach them
like if you're gonna break the rules you
you bought it you broke it you bought it
and you have ownership and you better
put more in the till by the end of the
day then you then you chuck out and you
have to think about can I afford to take
this money out of the till and am i
public spirit and what if something goes
wrong
hi agency you know there was just this
kid who apparently took the family sedan
from Utah to California he was five
years old and was pulled over on the
interstate because his parents forbid
him from buying a Lamborghini with the
lunch money and you know this
five-year-old kid is driving to
California successfully in the family
car I just thought I hope that kid
listens to the portal